[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis plus de 20 ans j'ai de la justice
la police analyse et des ordinateurs des
téléphones portables je recherche des
messages des images des vidéos dans le
but d'aider à comprendre un crime
ces éléments ce sont des traces
numériques les traces numériques
c'est quelque chose de fabuleux elles
permettent de comprendre le mobile du
crime
pourquoi il s'est passé et permet de
mettre en évidence les collusions entre
les personnes elle permet aussi de
comprendre comment le crime s'est
déroulé et enfin quelques fois comment
les personnes ont voulu camoufler leurs
crimes il ya quelques années en france
une femme est assassinée par son mari la
justice me demande d'analyser un
ordinateur et un téléphone portable
la date d'un simple appel téléphonique
va permettre de renverser la
compréhension du procès alors que tout
indiquait qu'il s'agissait d'un crime
commis sous l'emprise de l'émotion
cette trace avec d'autres éléments va
permettre d'établir la préméditation et
d'infliger aux criminels
une peine plus sévère l'accusé raconte
ainsi son geste il était avec son épouse
puis il dit j'ai pris le téléphone de ma
femme et j'ai vu des messages à
caractère romantique
j'ai vu des photos qui provenaient de
notre homme alors j'ai vu rouge
j'ai pris le téléphone je les briser et
je les jeter à terre puis j'ai saisi ma
femme et je les étrangler étranglé
étranglé jusqu'à ce qu'elle ne bouge
plus elle était morte
ensuite il dit qu'il s'est endormi
suite au choc émotionnel qu'il a eu avec
son acte le lendemain il prévient la
police
et la juge chargée de l'enquêté me
demande d'analyser le téléphone portable
et l'ordinateur de la victime à la
recherche de message à caractère
romantique de photos de disputes
conjugales
je fais ces recherches je trouve
quelques éléments effectivement je les
consignes dans un rapport et puis je
remets ce rapport à la justice mon
travail était terminé mais la faire elle
n'était pas terminée deux ans plus tard
on me demande de témoigner je me rends
alors devant la cour et j'explique ce
que j'ai trouvé sur les ordinateurs les
téléphones portables et puis j'attends
les questions la présidente du jury me
demande alors mais quelle est la date du
dernier appel émis à partir de ce
téléphone portable alors je consulte mes
notes je relève l'information et puis je
transmet à la cour
hélas la présidente me dit et monsieur
l'expert il s'agit du lendemain du crime
l'accusé dit qu'il a brisé le téléphone
dans un accès de fureur la veille
est-ce que ce téléphone briser la veille
pouvait passer cet appel le lendemain le
téléphone était coupé en deux il ne
pouvait plus fonctionner c'est alors que
les jurés ont commencé à comprendre que
la version donnée par l'accusé étaient
faussés et commencé à s'écrouler la
trace numérique a permis de démonter sa
version avec d'autres preuves
cette trace a permis de montrer que la
thèse qu'il défend des du crime
passionnel ne pouvait pas tenir
en fait il s'agissait clairement d'un
crime prémédité
alors la trace numérique c'est quelque
chose de très important très utile mais
surtout très récent quand elles
n'existaient pas comment faisait ton
pour élucider un cas pour traiter une
affaire
alors vous allez me dire il ya
l'empreinte digitale et vous avez raison
la première fois que l'on a utilisé les
empreintes digitales
c'était à la fin du 19e siècle
dans un petit village d'argentine une
femme avait tué ses deux enfants puis
elle avait accusé son voisin du double
meurtre
et elle avait aussi dit que ce voisin
avait essayé de la tuer elle
d'ailleurs elle s'était infligé quelques
coups pour accréditer sa thèse
un inspecteur et dépêché depuis la ville
voisine il arrive à cheval dans le
village ils regardent la scène de crime
et il aperçoit sur une porte une tâche
ensanglanté cette tâche ne pouvait avoir
été laissé que par le meurtrier
il s'approche la trace est une trace de
doigt alors ils découpent le goût de
portes et puis il prend les empreintes
digitales de la femme du voisin et de
quelques autres personnes et puis
retourne à cheval à la ville il analyse
les traces effectivement l'empreinte
digitale est celle de la femme
elle avoue alors le double meurtre elle
voulait refaire sa vie avec un autre
homme
alors lui voulait bien d'elle mais pas
des enfants
l'empreinte digitale a permis
d'identifier la meurtrière
pour autant cette empreinte n'a
absolument pas permis de connaître
pourquoi elle avait tué ses enfants la
façon dont elle les avait tués
si elle avait eu des complicités et
comment elles avaient camouflé son crime
il existe maintenant des méthodes plus
modernes
l'analyse adn qui peut amener plus
d'informations la première fois que
l'analyse adn a été utilisé c'était en
angleterre au milieu des années 80 à la
suite du viol et du meurtre de deux
jeunes femmes un suspect a été arrêté un
homme simple d'esprit
il comprenait pas trop ce qui se passait
ils voulaient bien avouer le meurtre
d'une des femmes mais pas de l'autre un
scientifique qui est elle a alors
proposé de prélever du matériel
génétique sur les vêtements des deux
jeunes femmes et de le comparer à l'adn
du suspect donc ils prélèvent l'adn sur
les vêtements
ils les comparent déjà et il se rend
compte que c'est la même personne qui a
tué qui a violé et tué ses deux jeunes
femmes
mais ce n'est pas l'adn du suspect la
police alors organise un vaste
recensement génétiques sur plus de 5000
personnes de la région
on prélève 5000 adn ils sont tous
comparer mais là encore aucun ne
correspond
la police ne sait que faire
jusqu'à ce qu'un homme arrive et 10
j'ai un ami qui m'a demandé de me
présenter aux tests de prélèvements à sa
place parce qu'il ne voulait pas être
inquiété pour des infractions routières
commises quelques temps auparavant
la police va chez l'homme l'arête
prélève son adn et il correspond à la
scène de crime
c'est la première fois que l'utilisation
de l'adn permet la résolution d'un crime
c'est aussi la première affaire dans
laquelle un homme est innocenté suite
aux tests adn
le test adn tout comme l'empreinte
digitale pas cependant permis que
d'identifier le meurtrier
elle n'a pas permis de savoir pourquoi
il avait tué ces jeunes femmes
la façon dont il avait tué six étaient
entourés de complicité et s'il avait
voulu camoufler son crime
les traces numériques permettent
d'apporter plus d'informations sur ces
questions il ya quelques années à genève
une femme rentre chez elle c'est le soir
elles se trouvent devant la porte de sa
maison quand tout à coup un individu de
forte corpulence surgit et l'étranglent
violemment il la laisse pour morte cette
femme survivra miraculeusement la police
conclut à un brigandage à un vol qui
aurait mal tourné
prélève quand même des traces adn sur
les vêtements de la jeune femme
le temps passe six mois après la police
genevoise
arrête un homme qui vient de tirer avec
une arme à feu sur un autre homme comme
il est d'usagé son adn est prélevé
comparé aux fichiers et là on s'aperçoit
que son profil génétique est le même que
celui de l'agresseur de la femme
la police lui demande alors mais c'est
bien vous qui avait agressé cette femme
mais pourquoi alors lui dit oui c'est
bien moi
mais en fait j'étais payé c'était un
contrat
la police alors bien sûr continue de
l'interroger saisi son téléphone
portable
regarde ses relevés téléphoniques et au
bout de l'investigation identifie trois
autres personnes impliquées dans cette
tentative d'assassinât dont le mari qui
a été l'instigateur
la procureure en charge de la faire me
demande alors d'analyser tous les
portables et tous les relevés
téléphoniques de tout ce beau monde
je fais mon analyse est là se dessine le
mobile du crime
le mari ruiner dans des investissements
douteux voulait récupérer de l'argent de
sa femme la suite de l'investigation on
recherche on s'aperçoit comment il a
contacté ses complices comment ses
complices se sont entendus comment ils
ont prémédité le crime
comment ils l'ont réalisé et comment ils
ont tenté de le camoufler
je vous ai relaté quelques exemples
d'actes physiques sur des personnes ou
via des personnes mais qu'en est il des
actes malveillants commis sur internet
ou sur des machines où se trouve
l'empreinte digitale de la machine
comment prélever son adn
la présence humaine maintenant dans les
crimes est absente
pourtant la volonté humaine elle elle
est bien présente
derrière ces actes la trace numérique
est alors primordial pour atteindre
l'humain qui est derrière les machines
et pour comprendre les mobiles d'un
crime
pour comprendre comment ce crime s'est
déroulé pour comprendre des complicités
et tentative de camouflage la trace
numérique
la preuve numérique maîtrisé par celles
et ceux qui la comprenne est un atout
majeur dans notre société
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]